kari is so good to see you very nice to
see you
so i was watching this last night and i
thought
i got to find the biggest screen i can
find for this series like it feels like
it should be in the movie theater
and you're bringing that feeling what
were your goals
when you approached this project you
know the
real core goal was besides
going on a fun ride with these two
characters who are going to uh take us
through
lots of twists and turns as we um as we
take up the shield conversation and
uh will sam pick up the shield or will
he
not pick up the shield um i think i also
wanted it to be
quite immersive and you've picked up on
the sort of big screen of it
uh it was to really feel as experiential
as possible
so the action sequences even even um
being in a
room with two people i wanted us to feel
very much like we were part of the
you know we were a character in the room
with them
and with so many characters in the mcu
even
even with all the movies that we've had
one of the things that people don't have
a chance to get to know them better and
now we can see
even with wanda vision what we saw we're
getting a chance now with these series
to really delve into the relationships
and even the psyches of these characters
is that something that you were very
excited about doing expanding on who
these people are
absolutely you know what's terrific
about a six-hour movie which is how we
approached it
uh is that you get time you know and and
so you're allowed to
spend some time with the characters and
go down you know that road with them
so that you can learn what's behind the
moment you know
what what are they struggling with what
are their um you know
in the case of sam he's got some family
issues he's
trying to cope with in the case of bucky
of course he's trying to figure out
where he sits on the planet why he's
here how to go forward
um you know with the carrying the
suitcase of trouble that he has
so um but you get time to to to
get to know them i i think that's going
to be very exciting for the fans because
they've never really been able to spend
this kind of you know
quality quality time with their
characters
we're seeing in this phase um with you
directing executive chris in this series
jack schaefer even with the eternals
coming up chloe directing that
um we're it's finally the time we're
seeing women taking charge of these
uh series and these movies and getting
to tell them from their perspective
can you talk about how how special that
is and why that's
right so important right now well i
think it just adds to the conversation
uh of diversity um and it goes to prove
that it is happening and that there's a
real support
uh to hear the voices and i'd like to
think that
um we're freshening uh you know by
including
all the different voices that come with
that that the
um there's a fresh take you know it's
not
uh the same old same old and so it's
shaking it up
on on in every way possible uh including
uh you know even on set
and the dynamics on set um so i you know
it's very current with the times because
between all the different movements um
everybody is basically saying
join the revolution and that's what this
is and so uh i was thrilled to be part
of um
you know uh i've always i suppose
been um you know part of uh blasting
through
whatever ceiling i i came across so
it didn't feel like it was uh terribly
new territory for me
um uh having said that um i was thrilled
to be part of you know this whole
new big theatrical kind of
uh scenario where women are starting to
really shine
well kari being canadian and not just
being canadian i mean
we're rooting for you and i'm personally
a big fan of your work i'm so excited to
see the rest of this series thanks for
this time
thank you